we got breaking news out of Provo Utah a
man who was posting threats against the
president had his home raided by the FBI
where he was shot and killed and this
story is uh currently spreading hundreds
of thousands of tweets as everyone's
talking about it and there's a couple
different views either way I see it as
escalation you either have the story of
a deranged man on the internet
threatening to harm the president
or you have the story of an overzealous
FBI targeting a morbidly obese elderly
man who was a threat to no one either
way you break it both sides are looking
at this as some kind of escalation and
there's a lot more than just that we're
now learning that Twitter was fined 350
000 for snubbing the FBI subpoena they
were trying to dig into Trump's social
media and apparently Twitter in some way
obstructed them
Elon Musk has previously stated that the
government had full access to everyone's
private messages their DMS and it seems
uh in all likelihood Elon was actually
blocking this so we'll talk about that
we got a bunch of other stories that we
can get into before we do my friends
head over to castbrew.com we have big
news if you want to support the show you
can buy our coffee brand which is cast
brew and we have K-Cups available now so
if you want to get all of your favorite
coffee Blends you can buy them we got
rides with Roberto Jr got Appalachian
nights Mr bocus pumpkin spice we got
sleepy Joe decaf on woke decaf we got
stand your ground take all of it buy it
support the show but I also have an
announcement to make we are going to be
retiring the official brand of rise with
Roberto Jr because Roberto Jr has passed
away unexpectedly yesterday he had a
heart attack however the coffee will
just be renamed a new package in memory
of Roberto Jr and will introduce a new
blend for his father Return of the King
Roberto so what we have available right
now in terms of the rise with Roberto Jr
original art once that sells out we will
not be printing any more of these bags
we're making a new art uh in memory of
Roberto Jr so
you know buy it now if you want to if
you want them it's one of my favorites
of course and uh buying Casper supports
the show you can join the cast Brew
Coffee Club also head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member if you'd like to hang out in our
uncensored members only show now I know
a lot of people are asking about what
happened to last night's episode this
happened before it's on rumble's end you
know I'm not trying to drag them we're
big fans we love Rumble but sometimes
there are errors and there's nothing we
can do to to to remedy it we can try to
re-upload but then sometimes you get the
same error usually it resolves itself
but uh uh we are we'll trying our we'll
try our best and and I think you know
one of the issues is that by the time we
find out because the live the Live
members only goes up we're all here
we're all watching everything's fine
by the time we find out the next day
that it's down the crew's not here and
then we could potentially re-upload it
we get to drive and all that stuff so
we're gonna try and figure out a
methodology which will Rectify this
shouldn't happen again usually post
anyways it it fixes itself later but for
everybody who wants to watch it the next
day it's like it's not there so but
become a member we're gonna have an
episode uh on uncensored live tonight at
about 10 pm and we'll take your calls
calls from the audience you can call in
and talk to us and our guests smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
take the URL right now for this YouTube
live stream video and share it wherever
you can that really really does help
Word of Mouth podcasts grow joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is read Coverdale hey Tim
thanks for having me back on absolutely
who are you what do you do yeah uh I
have the naturalist capitalist podcast
which actually haven't done lately just
because I've been working so much but
I'm from New Hampshire I'm a Libertarian
uh the shirt I'm wearing if I want to
get one thing out is uh defend the guard
this is legislation that we're trying to
pass around the country we haven't
officially declared war since World War
II and every police action that's taken
place since then the National Guard has
been sent overseas which is
unconstitutional if each state passes
this the president can no longer send
troops overseas without declaring war uh
so that's something we definitely need
to pass right on well thanks for hanging
out we got Phil hanging out how you
doing I am uh philibonti lead singer of
the heavy metal band All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
Ian crosson what's up everybody let's
rock and roll yeah surge.com uh yeah
regarding the rebel thing you heard it
here from Tim so stop contact me on
Twitter thank you all right everybody
here's the big breaking news we got this
from The Daily Mail Utah man Craig Delhi
you Robertson was shot dead by the FBI
in raid after posting on Facebook a
credible Joe Biden death threat ahead of
the president's visit to Salt Lake City
they say Craig Robertson 75 was gunned
down on his doorstep by agents in Provo
an hour from Salt Lake City after they
were alerted to his spouse about the
president messages posted on what is
believed to be his Facebook page on
Tuesday included bloodthirsty content
about how he would I'm gonna I'm gonna
be light on this one but just let's see
post and death threats very serious
stuff saying the state would be famous
for the actions he would commit really
really messed up stuff now the
commentary that we're seeing from uh
many on the right that this guy is 300
pounds he's elderly he can barely walk
even with a cane and wasn't a threat to
anyone so I'm gonna give you my
immediate speculation in a second but I
want to say this first you've got the
left basically saying this is the danger
of the far right far right extremists
threatening the president oh heavens
help me you have people on the right
being like due to some old fat guy
posting on the Internet it's ridiculous
but the mo the the best response that
I've seen is
every single time someone threatened
Donald Trump nothing happened all of
these prominent leftists high profile
individuals made death threats against
Donald Trump nothing happened Kathy
Griffin held up a a pic a a mock severed
head of the president nothing happened
this guy posts really awful things
nobody should be posting that stuff the
FBI immediately shows up to his house he
gets gunned down now here's what I think
I bet
you know they see these posts so they're
gonna go and they're gonna knock on his
door and they're gonna figure out who he
is what he's doing they're probably
gonna arrest him many people have faced
similar things I'm willing to bet this
guy showed up armed and that was it
yeah he look I mean
first of all like there's no part of me
that's gonna defend this dude because
like you can't threaten to to kill the
president
at all I just I think it's I think the
whole thing is funny because he's dead
because like it's dumb to threaten to
kill the president and then was he like
500 pounds or something people are
saying he was 300 pounds he can walk 75
years old but it's a big dude but like
when the cops come to your house you
don't need to like it's odd to get into
a gunfight with the cops like that
should be thought of as as a that should
be infrequent you know I think this is
indicative of escalation because what I
think happens is sure this guy may not
be able to actually carry out any of the
things he's threatening because he's
morbidly obese and elderly but he
certainly had some kind of intent now
look Maybe I'm Wrong maybe the cops shut
up knocked on his door and he was
sitting in his couch you know covered in
Cheeto Dustin said hey look man I was
just posting nonsense and they were like
too bad and then shot him which I really
doubt yeah what likely happened is he
was angry and said oh you want to come
to my house over my you know you know
from my cold dead hands I bet he said
something about the freedom of speech
too get off my property kind of thing
yep and then he was probably armed
because we know the dude had a bunch of
weapons and so
that this is this is this is what
happens but I will I will I will stress
did we get any raids when people were
threatening Donald Trump no I've heard
stories of people getting their doors
knocked down and guys being like don't
you do that I have a question like um
his posts were direct statements that he
was going to do something yeah where the
Kathy Griffin thing is more of like no
that I hope this guy dies well hers was
just her standing there with this ever
had was that even mean yeah have there
were there documented cases where people
were literally threatening to
assassinate yes yeah okay yeah there was
there was a dude who rushed the stage
and tried grabbing a weapon from a cop
and then and I'm pretty sure that dude's
still alive
there was that moment where the guy
rushed the stage and then Trump grabs
the podium spins around Secret Service
tackles him there was another moment
where a guy went into a theater and
tried grabbing a gun from a cop and they
fought him and stopped him and there
were tons of people posting threats on
social media and we're all sitting here
going like yo this is crazy these people
are losing their minds
so I think everybody's I I that's why
I'm saying escalation
because this guy may not be a threat but
yo
what is what is the saying those who say
don't know and those who know don't say
there are people out there who probably
feel the exact same way as this guy and
they ain't saying anything they're not
going to go on social media and post
about what they're going to do or what
their plans are we we don't and and this
is the the threat of complete and total
destabilization the best case scenario
is
the Republicans launch a massive bout
harvesting operation
they utilize
ground activists to go door-to-door
Donald Trump wins in 2024 they clean up
the corruption they fire tons of people
there are criminal charges and trials
and that's it we move on the worst case
scenario in any capacity is anyone
escalating this to some kind of
high-level conflict
I don't know about high-level conflict
but I don't I don't I I definitely see
more escalation in the future right
you know I
I just don't people people need to
understand dude I still don't see the
off ramps you know I agree people need
to understand what life is like when
conflict conflict erupts and I think one
of the reasons why they're in history
there are stories of countries and
undergo Revolution and that's it and
there are stories of countries that
undergo Civil War
and I think the issue is that for people
in these countries that face Revolution
things get so bad most people just say
whatever because I'm gonna I'm gonna try
and survive when Civil Wars break out
it's highly political and people are
like there's a better way to do things
they fight each other over over the way
things need to be
my concern here is
it feels like either we enter some kind
of dystopian nightmare
or it turns into some kind of full-on
conflict
yeah I think with this particular
incident it's like Phil said it depends
on what happened when they showed up I
mean if we find out more if he started
shooting back at them right as they
showed up
I mean that's just kind of what you
expect to happen if you start shooting
at the FBI and
um especially if you're not able to yeah
but
um I mean I I do think the escalation
thing is a problem uh on your point
about you know the Republicans sweeping
all this corruption out
do you foresee that happening in any
capacity like because Christopher Wray
the FBI director he was appointed by
Trump and and predicating what Trump
will do based on what he did is a
mistake they betrayed Trump Trump's
angry and wants revenge so I expect
something different from him that being
said
I'm not gonna I'm not saying it's a high
probability or like the best probability
but who else you're gonna vote for yeah
it's like Rhonda Sanders ain't doing it
like if it's a 20 chance that Trump
would be success would successfully
clean out the government like that's way
better than any other anyone else that
would be I'm not good you know I'm not
gonna bet on Donald Trump being a good
dude who wants to save America a lot of
people are that's their bet my bet is
that they they betrayed Trump and Trump
Wants Revenge I think Trump won Trump
wanting revenge is something you can
count on yeah see I'm actually this this
has surprised a lot of people but I plan
to vote for Trump currently even though
I've been one of his largest critics for
how he handled lots of things uh but I
don't necessarily see him actually
fixing anything or
beheading you know figuratively
beheading a lot of his past uh
appointees
um I just think he's gonna drive people
crazy and that's enough for me like just
to drive the Liberals insane and make
everybody madly gonna drive I don't
think the Deep state will let him win I
don't think they can't stop him well I
mean if they have proprietary voting
machines they can stop anyone they
didn't stop him in 2016. I know and they
may they realize their mistake and then
they stopped him and well he was stopped
in 2020 we should say I think
Republicans screwed up in 2020 I think
Republicans were in on it it was
Republican and legislatures in certain
States who are passing these Universal
uh mail-in voting laws in Pennsylvania
they're the ones who helped Democrats
bypass their own Constitution so I'm not
worried about the Deep state I'm worried
about the Republican party but I think
if Donald Trump and his supporters
recognize the threats when it comes to
uh these these these you know Shady or
illicit voting strategies which were
done legally by the way they're just I
call them Shady if they recognize that
and Trump saying seems to be Trump's
going to win and they know it and look I
think it's plainly obvious they would
not be indicting him unless it was
possible for Trump to win if they if
they knew they could control voting
machines and they could do all this they
would not go anywhere near Trump they'd
be like oh geez oh no here's trump it
wouldn't matter who ran they'd say
please run get all your supporters riled
up no no they are so desperate to stop
him they're talking about indicting him
in Georgia next week they are throwing
everything and the kitchen sink at him
in a desperate bid to stop him because
they're not confident they can yeah you
know the only person who can stop Trump
is Trump
biggest he's his biggest he's his own
biggest hindrance and I mean in 2020
regardless of all the things you're
talking about Trump trump was just he
was running an awful campaign in 2016 it
was great he was the new guy on the
Block he was anti-establishment he was
going to go in and kick everybody out
who was ruining the country in 2020 it
was kind of hard to make that claim
after he'd been in there four years and
everything was falling apart and we're
passing all these giant spending bills
so I think it's really on him if he
wants to win is to really you know
listen to his base and try to understand
what they're empathizing with them on
because over the last couple years he's
been a little bit off you know like he's
cheering on stuff that they didn't
support and he's even getting booed at
rallies occasionally and when he did his
CNN Town Hall I saw the old Trump kind
of come back when he was pushing back I
forget her name to the CNN
um interviewer there and he was making
all the jokes that he had made in 2016
he was talking about how we need to end
the war in Ukraine I was like okay this
is the 2016 Trump that can win an
election so I think it's really up to
him if he wants to win
I agree I I don't want to push my my
hopelessness on you but I there's
there's no way there's no way only state
that will not stop that guy there's no
way it's just funny that it's like in
2016 he won and it's like he can't win
it's impossible but yeah but he he won
because they weren't expecting it they
made sure Bernie Sanders they weren't
expecting it though they propped him up
they thought he was going to lose to
Hillary they got rid of Bernie because
they wanted Hillary and then they got
easy opponent in Trump and then they
they saw their mistake they're like we
can never make that mistake again with
that I I think anybody who's telling you
that Trump can't win is actively trying
to sabotage our path well anyone saying
he can win and and fire everybody and
save the world is also leading you down
a dark path yeah I completely disagree
yeah it is our only solution the FBI
just rated a guy's house who is
threatening death and they killed him
the Solutions in the private sector it's
not these politicians the solution to
the weaponization of government private
sector we need control of our social
Media communication technology you need
to be able to talk to your community and
and rally and organize and support I
would I would agree on a cultural level
especially with Elon Musk buying Twitter
and then blocking government access to a
lot of the information that they've been
illegally I would say unconstitutionally
stealing
but we have got deeply corrupt
individuals who are weaponizing
government now the stories that I
introduced not even all of them that the
FBI was systematically going after
Catholics they're they're criminally
charging uh people who are walking on a
lawn in DC antifa is free to go in every
respect you've got story after Story of
death threats violence the left they're
getting away from it it is a
multi-faceted conflict I certainly
believe culture and yes to be fair
private sector is going to play an
outsized role in this but when it comes
to what is happening in government I am
specifically referring to how do we
solve direct short-term political
conflict and when you have people
threatening death what we need is
someone who's going to go in
fix the justice system in any way even
it means firing people and people who
keep saying no he can't win Trump can
never win I'm like dude you want you
might as well just go to El Salvador
right now because if you think
everything they're doing with
weaponizing the doj is unsolvable
because it's happening before our eyes
and they're going after they're going
after now Giuliani and Sydney Powell
Jeffrey Clark John Eastman if if you're
gonna sit back and say it is inevitable
it is hopeless then you should not be in
this country you should run you should
have run a long time ago oh no you can
acknowledge the Deep State and the power
they have over elections without being
black billed and giving up I mean but it
doesn't mean you got to bang your head
against the wall to create a hole like
there are other ways I think like Vivek
ramaswamy is a far superior candidate
and to act like Donald Trump's a better
vote because he's more popular I think
is is a mistake you should go for the
best candidate the the guy always go for
the best candidate that's how the best
candidate wins we'll see Trump is
actually my number three as far as
quality of candidate goes I actually
like are FK the most probably and then
probably vivec and then Trump I'm gonna
vote for Trump just because he's going
to cause the most chaos and the most
Anger from people I hate that's honestly
what I care about I love how you think
but what you're you would go with RFK
before I mean there's a lot of issues
slightly
because I I because I'm I'm totally not
on the RFK yeah wagon I'm not either by
the way I'm not one man but like
I like the fact that he's counter to
like basically like the the official
narrative or absent or however you want
to talk about it but like all of his
past uh oh it's bad positions are awful
this position on the Second Amendment
his position on on climate change and
and what to do about it and and if it's
you know the amount of human uh input on
climate change and all that all that
kind of stuff all those things are
terrible like so I'm super not into the
RFK guy at all like I know the other
thing is a lot of Libertarians are have
bought into that and I'm just I'm I'm
extremely apprehensive I I completely
understand the thing is uh the the
position he's running for the things
he's terrible on he doesn't have much
control over where the things he's
mostly good on he would have a lot of
control over and the things that he's
good on that he'd have control over in
the executive I slightly prefer him to
Vivek and Trump
well let's jump to this story from the
post-millennial because we got more big
news in the destabilization of this
nation breaking Biden doj finds Elon
Musk 350 000 after he refuses to give
them access to Trump's Twitter account
The District Court held accent contempt
for missing the deadline and the social
media platform was fined 350 000 I think
for Elon it's probably a drop in the
head but uh wow massive credit to uh to
uh Elon and X for basically telling the
government to go uh shove off we were uh
we were talking about this a little bit
earlier and and Reid had mention back
when uh Apple told the FBI to go piss up
a rope when the FBI was trying to get uh
get them to unlock a a terrorists
but then they eventually just figured
out a way to break in yeah but at least
Apple didn't help them do right you know
which is and credit to them and this to
me is kind of the same kind of situation
like uh credits to Twitter because
anyone that pushes back against the feds
when it comes to this type of thing I
think is a good is good so we also need
to protect that Twitter account at all
costs Donald Trump's Twitter oh yeah
well that belongs I'm of natural history
I mean of American History so he needs
to get back on it he uh he truth we have
this uh truth from real Donald Trump
reposted by election wizard he says just
found out that crooked Joe Biden's doj
secretly attacked my Twitter account
making it a point not to let me know
about this major hit on my civil rights
my political opponent is going crazy
trying to infringe on my campaign for
president nothing like this has ever
happened before does the First Amendment
still exist the deranged Jack Smith tell
the unselects to destroy and delete all
evidence these are dark days in America
I completely agree the the sitting
president
is trying to he this is beyond Watergate
what is this Joe Biden just tried to
steal private Communications from his
main political rival yes let me just
repeat that for everybody we now know
and Elon Musk obstructed this Joe Biden
running for president just tried to
steal the private Communications
unconstitutionally from Donald Trump
from his private account and only
because of Elon Musk they're obstructed
incredible
I think technically and I could be wrong
Twitter owns that account so it's
technically uh Elon musk's data and
account so they'd be if they were
stealing it they'd be stealing it from
Elon but it looks like they asked him
for it so it wouldn't have been theft if
that sounds like something the NSA would
say well I think I don't own any of our
social media any reasonable person would
argue that our data belongs to us I
would like it to but I think legally at
this point it doesn't but it should in
some on some sites maybe it does if it's
in their terms a lot of sites want to
own your stuff I gotta tell you I I
don't care what ridiculous psychotic
totalitarian Nazi BS the government
tries to argue about why they have a
right to to take my private
Communications they don't the Fourth
Amendment extends to what is my private
Communications and they can make all the
arguments in the world that when you
when you transmitted the message over
Twitter you gave that message to Twitter
now yeah that's like a BS argument from
Psychopaths who are trying to bypass our
constitution it would be like if you
went into somebody's house and had a
Converse station with somebody else in
that house and they were recording you
in their house and then you left like
technically that person's that owned the
house would own that communication now
that's kind of like Twitter no it's more
it's more like you have a it's more like
you uh ba you you rent a mailbox at a
big so so out in the middle of nowhere
people don't have mailbox in front of
their houses depending on where you live
they'll actually have a mailbox building
where everyone goes and collects their
mail despite having private houses they
go to one spot so you know where we are
up in the mountains these mail trucks
can't get on some of these roads
so we'll be more like they said that
mailbox isn't actually yours it's
property of the post office therefore
anything inside of inside of it is our
fair game to open and read I think the
post office can open and read your mail
they need probable cause the fourth
amendment protects us so I will make the
fair point that they're saying a judge
ordered this but that means very little
to me when it is the president trying to
steal the private Communications of his
chief political rival
that's a whole degree of f'd up yeah I
mean it just because there's a political
campaign going on or just because Donald
Trump is a Persona non-grad it doesn't
mean that the federal government can
just look into his private
Communications and there is an
expectation of privacy that you that
people have when they use platforms like
this you know so that's why they call
them private messages that's a big
mistake yeah that's why you need to
encrypt your messages and have
end-to-end encryption anything that is
unencrypted is viewable by every
government on well most of the
governments on Earth I would imagine at
this point you're totally right but the
average person doesn't you know but
that's like experience is not excuse you
know that's like saying The Government
Can spy on you unless you build a house
inside of a faraday cage it's like no if
you don't have Christians is to stop
them from doing it like it's if you
don't have curtains on your windows no
Constitution is going to stop the cops
from looking inside your that's that's
not a fair Affair analogy because when
you're sending a private message you are
not the average person does not believe
believe they're standing nude in front
of a window they think the curtains are
up so it would be more like the
government has goggles that can see
through your curtains and said well it's
your fault for only having regular
curtains
it's like what am I supposed you got to
put up lead curtains you do you do right
because the Chinese government well I
guess you are the foreign we're talking
about the United States government
trying to steal Trump's Communications
anybody can do it any government could
do it and that's not my concern my
concern is the U.S government violating
the rights of American citizens and Joe
Biden trying to steal Communications
from Trump to cheat an election
well I mean I think you did you just
point out it's not he got a judge's the
judge side it means very little when the
doj Joe Biden is targeting his political
opponent I don't care criminally
charging Trump I don't care they've
crossed the line they're engaged in
Civil War I don't disagree with you but
I have no empathy for people that
continue to text on their phones with
proprietary software to type on direct
messages on Twitter and YouTube without
saying this stuff like that is trackable
data through your head I have no empathy
I have tons of sympathy for people who
eat Splenda and drink fluoride and do a
whole bunch of other really awful things
because the government tells them it's
fine yeah well they should because there
are there are people who should know
these things but it's not the job of the
average person who's a plumber or a
carpenter or who works at an insurance
company to read the news and do the
research every day that's what we do and
so we try to inform them we try to tell
people hey man you gotta encrypt your
messages hey you got to eat healthy you
gotta exercise and you got to pay
attention to what's going on to the best
of your abilities but the point is the
average person yeah oh people are out
there building houses okay they're
working eight 12-hour days they're not
gonna go online and research fluoride
for 27 years to figure out what's going
on with the water or atrazine or or
sucralose or other stuff like that so
they come to shows like this and we do
our best to inform them to the best of
our abilities so I do have sympathy for
people they think their messages are
private because it's only between them
and another person if there was a big
red stop sign on the on the thing that
said anyone can see this they would take
it much more seriously but they're not
being told that they're being misled
outside of all of that the most
important thing to consider it doesn't
matter whether or not Donald Trump can
be spot on by China or Australia or any
other country it doesn't matter if
private messages are not secure what
matters is even if I paint a big picture
and I put it in my bedroom the federal
government does not have a right to come
and take it without a warrant in this
instance the chief political rival is
being targeted by the sitting president
for political purposes you're not going
to make an argument about warrants in
that case the Constitution has been
ripped to shreds and Joe Biden is
cheating to try and steal 2024.
I think it's interesting that the
federal government often uses foreign
governments as a scare tactic to let
them just you know have open season on
your uh private messages too like the
restrict act that's what the the tick
tock ban is what it was being sold as
because China's harvesting our data or
whatever but then the restrict Act was
just basically a patriot act for all
social media companies five Eye spy Club
this is what they do
the United States Canada New Zealand
Australia the UK
each of them go to each other and say it
is illegal for us to spy on our citizens
you spy on them then share the data with
us and now it's allowed
that's how they bypass our human rights
and you know that they they've their
stories that I've heard that they're
people that abuse it like dudes are
asking people hey can you watch my
ex-girlfriend and that kind of stuff
like you know oh yeah yeah I think
there's no good Revelations showed that
right yeah because they because they if
you're you know if you're working in the
Intel community and stuff you're gonna
end up getting friendly with other you
know with other uh other countries with
other people in in the Intel Community
for other countries I've worked on the
social media from the inside and it
feels like walking down dark alleys at
night in big cities like don't do it
don't post your data publicly in direct
messages on Twitter if it's not
encrypted do not do it because you're
putting yourself in a vulnerable
position if you do that and if you're
taking advantage of yeah you can blame
the victim but like
like oh she had it coming because what
she was wearing but like you just don't
go down if you if you continue to go
down those dark alleys I mean I just
don't have sympathy for those people if
if you know that there's a a risk
involved but you're going to do it
anyway just because you're lazy or you
don't care I screw off like you deserve
it like eat it I don't know what I tell
you reality is reality like if you're
not going to protect yourself you're not
gonna be protected
yep
the problem with end-to-end encryption
is that if the person on the other end
of your message shares that message with
somebody uh well that's true that's not
private yeah that's true if you go to
someone and say hey don't tell anybody
but you know X Y and Z and then they go
hey everybody x y z secret was
meaningless but uh elon's doing a great
job I think he's working on end-to-end
encryption for all direct messages I'm
not sure if they've implemented yet but
it's probably for this reason
I think Elon would prefer not to get
fined you know 350 million 350 uh 350
000 and it's easier if everything's just
encrypted he can go here you go and it's
a bunch of exactly he doesn't have the
thing to give them so they can't find
him that's how mines does it they don't
hold the keys only the keys only belong
to the people that are sending the
messages
it's crazy what's going on right now in
this country man we have this story from
the post millennial fourth indictment
against Trump expected in Georgia next
week Willis has stated that she plans to
announce potential charges by September
1st at the latest
I don't know what to tell you man
everything we see happening
what do you think is going to happen in
in 2024 you think there's going to be
it's going to be some peaceful everyone
comes and shakes hands and smiles with a
degree of psychotic behavior I mean they
just done the guy down and killed him in
his house yeah whether you're I'm not
making a comment on anything other than
that that a guy died
I we with the with the uh the level of
intensity that now I feel like it's a
kind of Calm before the storm kind of
thing because it has it has been really
chill like news wise when it comes to
the actual election and stuff there
there hasn't been any kind of big
developments to talk about uh I mean we
keep talking about you know this
DeSantis kind of just petering out
that's been the big story for days and
days and days or you know maybe vevik is
is getting some traction stuff but it's
still it's mostly very chill you know
not not big announcements or anything
like that so I feel like you know the it
is the Calm before the storm and it's I
feel like it's going to be really really
weird with AI and the way that and the
way that's gone yeah they've only just
begun yeah and I think that like I said
now is the Calm before the storm but I
think that once once the election starts
or once the campaigning starts getting
you know going in Earnest it's gonna be
really weird with
people aren't going to know what to
believe you're not and it's going to be
really weird I don't know that I don't
know that anyone's ever going to feel
confident about who won a an election
ever again just because they're gonna
feel like they I don't know that people
are gonna feel like they confidently
can say that they made an informed
decision that was actually informed by
the truth as opposed to you know really
propagandized so I think it's going to
be a mess whether Biden or Trump becomes
an ex-president and I don't think we're
on the verge of some like Civil War I
think people are too lazy for it still
honestly like you might have a few
people who are real amped up uh but I
mean the FBI has been murdering people
for a long time that's you know I
understand that this is politically
charged but everything every murder the
FBI has ever committed in the past has
been politically charged so I don't
think this is necessarily a new thing
and uh you know if you're not online all
the time you talk to people like they're
a little worried about stuff but not
nearly at the levels that everyone is on
Twitter and social media so I don't
think that we're at the verge of any
sort of conflict when people one of the
things that I think when people say that
is I think of the the idea that there's
only a certain small percentage of
people that are involved in any kind of
like political
whether it be you know activists or
whether it be you know you know
um just going out and demonstrating or
protesting or whether it be people that
actually do you know get violent and
stuff it's it's always a small minority
of people that that get into you know
get into that stuff like Tim's talked
multiple times about how when he was in
Egypt like you know there was a the Arab
Spring was like literally kicking off in
Egypt but at the same time there were
people that were like you know at cafes
just going about their normal day and I
feel like the people that are on Twitter
and stuff are most likely the people
that are going to be would be the ones
that would be at least the most likely
to be politically informed so it seems
to me to be to make sense that those
people would be the most likely to be
politically active well up to including
you know violence I think you nailed it
it's it's never the majority it is never
it like
I I don't think there's there's a
there's for the most part a conflict in
history where the overwhelming majority
of a population was actively
participating in a conflict even in in
World War II we're looking at you know
what was like a million some odd uh
conscriptions in in in a country of at
the time what was it uh how many people
were around then it's a fraction yeah
it's a fraction I bet I bet that then
maybe we'll like 60 to 100 million or
something like that probably less
what is it in 1941 uh yeah 132 million
132 million and how many how many
soldiers did we construct a million I
don't know is somewhere around there
yeah so that's like you know what 0.7
.0 small percentage they were actively
engaged in the conflict and the reality
is the people were conscripted weren't
actual participants in the conflict in
the sen in the political sense it was
like I gotta tell you I bet most people
didn't care
and if you went around I bet there were
people going like yeah but if you ask if
you ask your neighbor they don't care
about Germany or what's going on yet
somehow we found ourselves in that
conflict so what I see happening you get
this guy he's posting on social media
saying this horrifying stuff you get
antifa you get violent extremists who go
out and the majority of people will
cower but conflict happens eventually
what happens is the question of who's in
charge there's that a moment met taibi
wrote about where two cars speed towards
the police station two men in suits jump
out run full speed up to the door run
inside and run to the police chief and
say arrest that man and point to each
other
and now the police chief says uh which
one do I arrest who's in charge what
happens then there's a bunch of
different ways these things like this go
you have Revolution you have military
Takeover in Egypt the military took over
the military just decided you know what
the civil unrest is too much and they
removed the president twice in the span
of I think like a year but most people
aren't paying attention to that I look
outside and they're the guys sitting at
McDonald's watching soccer he doesn't
care I went to the mall in heliopolis
while the revolution is taking place in
Egypt and people were just shopping for
cell phones and if you asked any one of
them not a single person cared and then
a day later the military removed the
president who was duly elected why he
was he was a Muslim and the secular
people in the country there was there
were more secular people than Muslim
Brotherhood supporters but the Muslim
brother was the largest faction of
Voters so they won it was a legitimate
first pass the post-election military
said we don't care but the average
person out shopping
I go to a cafe I'm having coffee
nobody's talking about it now you
actually go out and you'll you'll hear
people talk about it so it's worrying to
me in that I don't expect the average
person to care I'm concerned about the
people who are politically active and
motivated and I'm concerned with look if
the reality is you're right nobody cares
and no one's going to do anything then
we're dealing with a federal government
that has just Amplified their corruption
100 fold to the point where they're like
Watergate was a scandal this apparently
Joe Biden's still the good guy that is a
degree of corruption and malfeasance we
have never seen in this country before
and what nothing's happening yo this it
breaks down if nothing happens if we
don't have a new like the the best case
scenario for everybody
Trump or Vivek or or even Rhonda Santos
any one of these guys who pledges to
fire people the best case scenarios they
do get elected they do fire people they
do start weeding out corruption and we
turn this ship upright and we start
saving it otherwise the two scenarios
are overt conflict between angry
political factions or
Revolution yeah what bothers psychotic
despots go around and mercilessly beat
arrest and lock up innocent people what
gets me about these faction conflicts is
that I think if there's an enemy of the
United States they would want that to
happen it's very easy to destroy or take
over or surpass an enemy if they're in
fighting if they're in a middle of a
half the country's fighting itself so
they want people to walk outside and be
like hold on there I think you're the
enemy and the other person's like no no
hold on there you're the enemy I saw it
on TV they're like no I saw it on TV
that's what they want so if people are
brainwashed or afraid or domed then they
might do that but if so not only do we
need to weed out corruption within the
government itself we need to control the
media in a way or at least influence the
media so that people are not afraid of
each other maybe I think that's that's
naive I think when you have people like
these leftists who've come on this show
or the culture War who directly advocate
for giving children sexual explicit
content I don't know what you're what
you're arguing for you tell those people
I'm sorry I am not going to allow to
present this book of adult pictures to
Children you should be in prison and
they argue I've got 80 million people at
my back that tell you to stf you now
you've got a problem
um I'm I mean throwing people in prison
for advocating for a book is different I
didn't say anything about throwing them
in prison you just said you should be in
prison you just said that the forgiving
the pictures to Children these are the
people that came on this show no no I'm
saying the people who are giving these
books to kids should be in prison so the
80 million people at their back voting
in support of it and you ask them and
they'll deny it they'll say well I don't
know about that but they're certainly
complicit in it
I was just going to say I think the
federal government's a lost cause and
trying to come by all everybody and uh
peace again is not going to happen so I
think that separation and people going
to places where people think the same
way they are is the ultimate solution I
mean at this point you know when I see
conservatives crying about the Streets
of San Francisco and like how horrible
it's become I'm just like I don't take
them seriously anymore it's like why do
you care about San Francisco anymore
it's so obviously toast and gone or
Chicago because they vote in our federal
elections which have an impact on that
is the problem exactly not protecting
our borders whether or not the
government is increasing the tax rate so
when you have California bringing in
non-citizens and using that to inflate
their census number so they get more
votes in Congress and Electoral College
we've got a very very serious problem
with what San Francisco is doing yeah
well that's that's the problem right
there that they have control over us and
the solution is trying to decrease the
control that these other states have
over us the federal government needs to
decentralize instead of trying to fix it
and just get better people into these
positions we need to go back to a more
decentralized approach like the 10th
Amendment actually provided for yes but
I don't I don't completely agree with
that I I maybe would have agreed with it
a while ago but now we see the issue of
these west coast states
passing laws where people can kidnap
children and then sterilize them and the
state will protect the kidnapper
so there's a problem then when we say
everybody just pick your state and then
shut up okay what happens when you're in
Oklahoma
and uh is it is it Oklahoma let me make
sure I have my States right
what happens if you're in it might be
Kansas I got to make sure I think I
think it's Oklahoma
what happens when hold on yeah adjacent
to Colorado yeah yeah that's the point I
was going to make what happens when
you're in Oklahoma I think it's actually
either of them and uh
a woman you know you're with a woman she
gets pregnant and then she decides six
months on she doesn't want to be with
you so she flees to Colorado Colorado no
limit on abortion Oklahoma ban on
abortion
so what happens
yeah I I mean I understand why people
are uncomfortable with that thought but
at this point that's the only thing that
I think is going to save pockets of
society so I'm asking you what happens
next she goes to Colorado and gets
abortions and that man says well I guess
she's going to kill my son and then just
sits there and twiddles his thumbs well
that's the way it is now I mean to be
fair so right right now there is a it
it's that way now that's exactly what
I'm talking about it wasn't that way
before it used to be that there was a
certain like yes these things would
happen yes there are bad stories but the
more people geographically polarize from
from each other the more you're and the
more the culture divides and escalates
maybe abortion isn't the issue but you
run into that wall of there's going to
be uh uh a kid kidnapped there's gonna
be a there's gonna be a guy who lives in
a neighborhood
and he's going to have a creepy smile
and he's going to go on Tick Tock and
say kids don't listen to your parents
your parents are bad you should do
whatever you want I support you he's
gonna get a message from a kid who says
actually I live a few blocks away and I
want to get sterilization surgery and
the guy's gonna say I will drive you
personally to California to make this
happen he's going to kidnap the kid go
to California do you think the parents
are going to be like well guess my kid's
sterilized or do you think there's going
to be a conflict between the major
growing cultures between states yeah I
get your point is it the case where a
a third party not related to a child
could take a child yes it is yes wow yep
I think that's specific that might be
specifically in Washington however
Washington State yeah I think Washington
state was the one that explicitly said
anybody who who helps a child receive
gender affirming care will will not face
prosecution in their state so when we
live in a post-rational society which we
do there's no Universal reason anymore
and we live in a quasi-democracy where
the people of the country get to decide
what is right and wrong basically I mean
where is the win in the end there
getting rich
I mean there's no there's no moral win
in the end because you're dealing with
people who don't believe in the same
thing you do so that's why I'm saying at
this point in the game you should move
places where people do agree with you
because it's the only hope you're never
going to convert the country sure I I
don't completely disagree my point is
just that
you have to ask yourself what happens
after everyone
geographically polarizes
I think the liberal cities are going to
continue to fall apart I mean and then
what happens when people in cities don't
have food or water they're gonna leave
or they're gonna die I mean it's gonna
get bad but they're not just going to
leave
what so if you look at like New York
City liberal City most of the states
relatively red so what is the city going
to do when the city is struggling it
doesn't have food or water the same
thing the left always does steal it from
somebody else
the easiest thing to do is to go up go
up North and go to the rural farms and
just seize their food hey it's What
communists do they're going to say the
people need this more than you they
already do it in California with the
water they tell the farmers where the
lifeblood of the whole state and a good
portion of this country that they don't
have surface water rights because the
surface water has to go to the liberal
cities where people have voting power
then the poor people who live in these
in these farming districts lose access
to well water when the farmers drill
into the Earth to get groundwater to to
grow crops you can already see how that
starts to break down my experience in
California during the drought made me
understand the importance of the
Electoral College why it is absolutely
necessary uh and the Senate and and
Congress how the founding fathers did
this it's brilliant in California you
have poor migrant workers
and their Wells their well for water run
30 feet deep
there's Canal water running through this
in Tulare County and I ask the farmers
why don't you use that water there they
say we're not allowed to it's illegal
because the cities voted to take the
water and the politicians say well the
people need water first so what the
Farms do then is they drill tens of
thousands of feet thousands of feet into
the Earth for groundwater which drains
the groundwater and now all the poor
people have no water anymore their
30-foot Wells can't reach water and the
water stops
the Electoral College changes the way
the votes voting system would work now
you can't just go to this small or I
would say a republican system and I mean
that in the in the in the philosophical
sense not in the colloquial sense you
have to go to them and say we need you
all to vote we can't just vote to take
from you
so that's the point when you look at why
we break things down by States why they
have Senators so that you can't just say
we outvote you therefore we get your
water right and my statement is it's not
broken down enough have you heard of the
Free State of Jefferson initiatives and
California trying to break into three
different states right greater Idaho
yeah exactly those are the type of
things that need to happen because
you're right San Francisco and La
control an entire State now and that's
the problem is all that centralized
control so if that can be removed and
dispersed I think that's the only
peaceful solution it's not a peaceful
solution I don't disagree I think it is
a better move to make now
but when you have 10 million people in
the New York Metro and it's it's falling
apart and collapsing a decent amount of
them leave and a decent amount of them
will band together and say we deserve it
and then you get conflict you're gonna
have people in cities like the Colorado
River is a really interesting problem
the Great Lakes are a real interesting
problem you've got States I think it was
Arizona trying to sue to uh to claim the
rights over Great Lakes water arguing
the Great Lakes are part of the United
States and the water should be dispersed
and then you're the Great Lakes
Coalition fortunately because I believe
Ontario is a part of it it's now
International and other states can't
just drain the Great Lakes but the Great
Lakes need to be replenished they go
down if if there's too much consumption
I see what I see happening with places
like San Francisco and why I'm concerned
about them is that as they fall into
chaos those people who live there there
they need food and they need water they
need shelter and they want security and
if that falls apart even by their own
fault they will come and take it from
you and that means maybe they just move
to where you live and then start voting
for things that destroy your systems or
maybe they stay there it continues to
Decay and then eventually they just
start going and stealing from farms
passing laws where they lock Farms down
and claim property and you get communism
I mean how is that not happening under
our Federalist system we have now though
the same thing's happening they're doing
that so every single state if we had
property rights if we had a federal
system that actually enforced equality
under the law you have a lot less of
this now someone shows up and says I get
your farm they say I sue you now it goes
to the federal government they supersede
the state and say you can't do that you
can't take someone's Farm but that's
breaking down and that's the issue we
don't have a share like it's a it's a
combination of things not just
government its culture we don't have a
shared moral framework anymore you have
the rise of leftists and the funny thing
is the success of this nation gave rise
to weak-minded entitled individuals who
seek to steal from others without doing
any of the work and that leads to
collapse I mean these people vote so
they vote they vote to take and they
keep doing it and then what ends up
happening is one of two things as the
system starts to break down you either
get Revolution or well there's a few
ways reform is really possible but it's
really hard you're either going to get
Revolution or Civil War if it really
does escalate to that point and I kind
of feel like when we learned the doj is
going after Trump's lawyers
that that like look man it was already
unprecedented the doj went after Joe
Biden's political rival Donald Trump
unprecedented
now they're saying they're going to go
after Trump's lawyers the people giving
him legal counsel the government
basically saying if you provide
constitutionally protected services
legal representation to someone who we
oppose we're going to lock you up
there's there's an obvious next step to
this advocacy
they're already saying they were
political Consultants one of the
co-conspirators was a consultant not
even a lawyer someone who advocated that
Trump file uh these lawsuits and and
seek alternate electors the next step is
fairly obvious those who incite criminal
uh criminal actions they've already made
the claim that it's not free speech to
incite criminal activity right so now
when they say that Donald Trump's
actions in 2020 were criminal The Next
Step Beyond his lawyers is anyone who
publicly spoke advocacy for Donald
Trump's illegal actions was inciting
people to commit crimes and their next
so I think the South should have been
allowed to secede during the Civil War
and the Rewritten history about it is
that it was all about slavery that had
nothing to do with anything else and
that has built an American dream that
it's wrong to let people leave this
country and wrong to let people do their
own thing and that it's morally correct
to bind us all together as one country
if the South had actually left
I don't think you know the north was
kind of doing what you're describing
that leftists do is always trying to
reach out and get more power they were
taxing the South a lot more than they
should have been
um and so that type of thing is
happening now the you know the the
Reconstruction uh mindset has really
just like kept going and given us the
Progressive Era and destroyed this
country and unless we finally just break
off and say you know what we don't know
what we don't all belong under the same
system we need to have you know
different governments that you know
respect people the way they want to live
and you know I just I just think it's
the only way we can go forward and then
what what happens after that
uh I think that
the leftists are always going to want
more control like you said but the only
way to not give it to them is starve
them of it right what likely happens
after a separation if the United States
were to break into two and the left
called it like Jesus land and the United
States of Canada that's the meme they
put out the next likely thing to happen
is a unipolar Chinese Communist planet
where trade is going to be regulated
under their currency and their and their
rules and their whims and you're going
to end up with not NATO control but Brix
control that could go on for several
decades maybe 100 years who knows what
that means for Americans is well for one
it could mean less war it could mean
that we can live peacefully in farm in
our own States and mind our own business
but it means your standard of living
drops by some odd 90 percent and that
and that's you know I'm not saying
that's that's necessarily a bad thing I
mean the issue is the Petro dollar it
props up our economy and makes Americans
wealthy based off nothing when the when
this country splits into the Petro
dollar ceases to exist brics event brics
Nations basically take over the global
economy and oil trade and that means
Americans have to once again start
producing and we don't so for those that
advocate for this the end result is
going to be you will work more than
you've ever worked in your life and your
standard of living will be 90 lower me
personally
I don't mind tending to chickens and
animals and working on a farm and
reading books and just just working
every day
he's liberals and he's leftists they're
gonna cry they're gonna cry more they've
ever cried in their lives and they're
going to beg to bring back the Petro
dollar don't you think that's kind of an
inevitability at this point though like
it's that's why it's avoidable yeah I
mean well I mean look in in the event
that uh uh I really do mean it if you
get a Donald Trump of a vague or even
around DeSantis if they win and they
actually do follow through on the things
they've said it's not inevitable
there's act there's there's a there is a
possibility that we come out on top of
this successfully and that's that's
still sort of bad news for anti-war
individuals because the U.S machine just
keeps on keeping on but to fire corrupt
prosecutors to criminally charge corrupt
politicians and to reform and and
restore the actual uh like I don't want
to say uh moral framework of the past in
its entirety but the core moral
Frameworks of Classical liberalism the
founding fathers believed in then things
start to repair and strengthen but
you've got to get rid of the rot you got
to carve out the rot first and then
rebuild there's part of me that does
think that if you can
if you can wake up the average live
right the average liberal that gets
conned into illiberal things because
some authoritarian convinces them that
they'll be safer or they'll be looked at
you know as the nice guy or it's you
know it's racist to not do this or
whatever the the con from the the
progressives is if you can convince your
average bad liberal that they're being a
bad liberal and they need to come back
to things like
the rule of law the freedom of speech
that that things like the rule of law
has a big effect on you know the crew
the criminal element in your cities and
and that has a big effect on the economy
and if you can if you can remind
liberals that these things actually do
matter and that they're the way they've
been voting and and the behaviors of the
politicians they're electing are
actually illiberal then I think that you
could have a positive result without
some kind of massive Revolution but
without the people realizing that the
things that they're asking the
government to do are bad illiberal and
producing the results that they actually
don't like as long as people don't
realize that as long as they think that
voting for The then what sounds nice is
the is the proper course of action
there's not going to be any significant
change I just wanted to also add that
you know not just on a Warfare front but
on an economic front ever since we've
been on the Petro dollar the dollar has
lost you know all its value if you look
1971 we came off the gold standard
standard and then I think in 1974 we
went on the Petro dollar and ever since
then the dollar has just tanked so I
don't think it was a I don't think it
was a reliable system even with you know
competent leadership I don't think it
was sustainable I want to show you this
picture this is the only path forward
right here everyone take a look that's
it who does I'm just kidding this is
this is so I pulled up some AI images
that I made because I think they're
funny but uh look at this guy's hat like
this one guy over here is wearing a very
very tiny hat for some reason this is a
mid-journey made this it's uh
generalissimo Trump but uh I want to
show you another image
this is uh what the establishment fears
Donald Trump shaking hands with Sonic
the Hedgehog but uh this one is actually
the one I I want you to see because
if if you were to actually if you remove
Sonic the Hedgehog from this image it
actually looks like a real photo of
Donald Trump running down the street
there's the the average person's not
gonna be able to understand that this
was generated by AI
granted we put Sonic the Hedgehog in it
so we know this is not real this is what
I'm talking about with the with the
political battle that's that's coming on
uh coming up
this next year the Deep fakes that we
are going to see of audio a video it's
it's No One's Gonna know it's real there
is not I mean look if Joe Biden is
willing to steal the private
Communications of trump and try and lock
him up you think Democrats aren't going
to make fake audio of him fake videos of
him you're gonna do all that and more
can you I mean that that's the stuff
that that is is gonna be
really really difficult for people to
sort through because it's not going to
be it doesn't have to be like the
official DNC to produce something that
looks really good I mean we saw that
with the DeSantis uh they're gonna
Outsource a video that had the sauna ad
at the end well that was his campaign
who made that or the CC yeah what I'm
saying is it wasn't difficult for them
to make that it's not it's not difficult
for for a person like the Carpe uh
donctum or whatever his name like he was
doing that stuff in his own time it's
not like you need some big
infrastructure with with highly skilled
people you just need Photoshop or or
Lightroom or whatever your your you know
uh Daw now it's not a dog what's the I
don't know your program of choice so
um so yeah so yes your your point is is
well taken and and it's it's something
that is going to be
difficult to uh now I wanna I wanna
bring up this story for everyone who
said that Trump can't win Trump mocks
Chris Christie's weight Don't Call Him a
fat pig
made fun of yes of the former New Jersey
governor and 2024 Republican nomination
rival in a speech in New Hampshire it's
really funny because he said Chris
Christie he's eating right now he can't
be bothered when he said that there was
like 30 people in the media that were
just like yes he's back that's when a
man in the crowd shouted out to prod
Trump sir please do not call him a fat
pig I'm trying to be nice Don't Call Him
a fat pig you can't do that
that is the masterful anti-insult insult
of trump
when he goes on stage and he says you
know you've got uh Chris Christie some
people call him a fat pig we don't do
that it's a mean that's his that's his
game and it's brilliant because he's
insulting him what do you mean I said
don't call him a fat pig yo Trump's back
I saw that and I as soon as I saw the
story Don't Call Him a fat pig I busted
out laughing and I'm like this is what
Trump excels at he is an Entertainer he
builds confidence by being in control of
the stage and he's got it now
not to mention Chris Christie is very
pro-war so I don't know who's going to
vote for that guy anyway but uh I do
think this is a sign as silly and stupid
as it may be that Donald Trump has the
energy to win again I'd prefer a lot of
other people to be completely honest
only thing I'm really saying is I hope
Trump fires everybody
you know yeah I don't Trump is good at
firing people I'll give him that it's
just he's never been good at hiring them
so that's true and he wasn't his first
time around but I'm really hoping that
this time around he's just seeing red
the whole time yeah I know if it's Trump
great that's fine but for me it's like
look I want a president that's going to
significantly cut the government yeah
he's not your best bet
yeah he probably I mean compared to who
else again Vivek maybe I'm just saying
because just given like I expect him to
piss a lot of people off but I expect
him to sign tons of spending bills and I
mean just just looking at how he I mean
I know I'm a Libertarian but even if
you're a conservative judging how Trump
governed like gun control spending the
expansion of government like he was just
awful he's the only one that looks at
the uh
security establishment or the
intelligence establishment or whatever
as the enemy I agree with you there so
like do you know I I think that he would
make signals I just think that's in the
in the FBI I think it would make sense
do you think it makes changes like a
Personnel change I don't see him like
actually taking a hatchet to it but do
you know the extent of what he did with
the Drone program I know he made it uh
secretive and gave control to the
generals his support yes yeah I mean
they stopped recording how many drone
strikes were happening under his
presidency
um so they don't actually know what the
number is it was very high though
um you know people rightly point out how
many bombs Obama dropped because it was
abysmal but uh Trump uh I think he he
didn't drop more than Obama but he
dropped uh more in his first four years
than Obama did in either four-year
period so it was I mean he dropped a lot
of bombs and then he then there's a
bunch off the Record we just don't know
how many we don't know how much where
they were dropped or anything like that
do you think that what's your view of
how we handle say like Afghanistan or
Syria just complete instant removal of
all assets and Personnel so I think I
mean it's a mess no matter how you leave
the problem with Afghanistan I think I
talked about this last time I was on
here was the order of operations you
know like Phil said that you get the
people out first and then the military
at last but also
Donald Trump had made deals with the
Taliban about like Hey we're out of here
in May and then Joe Biden came in and
was dragging his feet and was like nope
I'm gonna make my own Taliban deal and
we're gonna leave in September and then
the Taliban was like well what the heck
why are you still here so you know there
are ways we could actually start pulling
troops out but Trump was actually
stifled by a lot of his generals he
wanted people out of Afghanistan he
wanted to start withdrawing and they
screwed him up
um that was one of the best things about
his presidency was the deal with the
Taliban and trying to pull him out so
the issue with the drone strikes is
if you immediately remove all the troops
you get what Joe Biden did
granted I think Joe Biden sabotaged
Afghanistan intentionally the the the
the abandoning of Bagram Air Force Base
was a psychotic move
what I see with Trump and this is not to
defend drone strikes should never have
been engaged in these wars I think
Trump's strategy was
stop increased drone strikes and pull
our troops out man once our troops are
out decreased drone strikes we're gone
well Trump increased troops in
Afghanistan in the beginning of his
presidency he did try he did start
trying to pull him out eventually but at
the beginning of his presidency on war
he was awful yeah he fires 59 tomahawks
into Syria he was just ramping
everything John Bolton and then toward
the end he was kind of like all right
all right all right you know maybe I
actually should pull some troops out but
so I I think one of the only ways you
effectively withdraw from Afghanistan in
the way that uh would be to you
basically use drone strikes as a
placeholder as you remove personnel and
then you rescind the drone strikes you
need you need a wall to stop what
happened and I think I think Joe Biden
as awful as what he did gave us a window
into into into how not to respond in
terms of the mistakes he did use a drone
strike though after
um
what was it after I after that Isis K
bombing right he did use a drone strike
and killed like 11 civilians with it or
something right right right and my point
is this
if you are trying to actively withdraw
all your troops from say Afghanistan you
you can't just recall them all instantly
there's got to be a tapered pullback of
certain areas you obviously don't
abandon Bagram Air Force Base my point
is that I think Trump's strategy
probably not even his but probably some
advisor was
increase the drone strikes to create
pressure get our troops out decrease
drone strikes release pressure we're
gone
I think the problem with Afghanistan was
extending the leave date by like six
months so that's Joe Biden that is Joe
Biden all right and then Joe Biden says
we're going to pull our troops out
abruptly in the middle of the night
without informing any of our partners in
the region without informing the Afghan
security forces and then they're left
with no Logistics so you got guys flying
helicopters being like where am I going
for fuel who's is anyone there what's
happening just gone in an instant
Optics it was all because he didn't want
of course it was Trump's yup Afghanistan
withdrawal plan yep
I mean what an evil piece of garbage it
wasn't 19 people died because of it yeah
I mean I think more than that we're
talking about 19 Americans right yeah
yeah
how many how many how many civilians a
lot yeah bystanders are caught up in
this and now living under the Taliban so
I mean it's you know Joe Biden is plenty
fair game but also George W bush is who
everyone really should hate we didn't
need to be in Afghanistan for 20 years
we could have had Osama Bin Laden in
2000 it wasn't we I do not believe the
U.S went to Afghanistan for Osama Bin
Laden no they didn't they went there for
poppy for heroin and oil and lithium
lithium they didn't go there for heroin
they went there for lithium there's
actually photos of U.S soldiers guarding
poppy fields right they were harvesting
and that and and that may be a component
but I think it was probably resources
strategic access a a pincer move on Iran
access to lithium seizing the region
before China or Russia could take it and
nation building and they use Osama Bin
Laden as an excuse to launch that
Invasion and they use wmd as an excuse
to invade Iraq why
anybody know geography it rocks over
here Afghanistan's over here Iran be
right in the middle
John Bolton Said I think it was in 2018
by this time next year we'll be
celebrating in Tehran it was that's what
that's what their goal was I I I'm glad
you brought up George Bush because we
talk a lot about how Biden is the worst
president ever in people's lifetimes a
lot of people will say that it was
George Bush it was George Bush yeah that
guy started this the worst 911 war on
terror crap the Patriot Act all the war
that we've seen in the Middle East was
started by those people all the power
that the Democrats are using against
conservatives now with the Department of
Homeland Security and everything you can
thank George W bush I think to be fair
though we can say that Cheney was the
worst president because I don't think
George I almost said that Dick Cheney I
believe maybe you can confirm this read
that George Bush had actually given
authority of the Air Force to Dick
Cheney do he is that what it was he had
on 9 11 it was Cheney's call oh yeah you
fly the planes to defend the tower yeah
it was Cheney's called a not shoot down
the plane that hit the Pentagon
daddy's boy getting into Power mess of a
presidency and then they put his dad's
buddy in as the VP to let him run the
show if you don't mind me going on a
short side Trail here just because vivec
put out a Vivek Rama Swami put out a
great tweet about 9 11. UM and it was
about flight 77 it was about the uh
hijackers who flew flight 77 into the
Pentagon kalid almidar into waffle
housemate and how they had Saudi royalty
directly wiring or indirectly wiring
them money uh prince bandar who was the
uh Saudi ambassador to the United States
wired money to Meyer all by Omi in the
United States and then he gave it to uh
Khalid almadar and the waffle housemate
who later flew the plane into the
Pentagon and this is something that a
lot of 9 11 conspiracy theorists
completely missed because it's flashy
and sexy and everything to deny a plane
hitting the Pentagon honor deny a plane
going down at Shanksville but if you
just deny these things instead of
looking into it you actually find out
that the true anomalies of people doing
Shady things are mostly involved with
flight 93 and flight 77 and I'm not the
expert on this I just know people who
are Ryan Dawson Adam Fitzgerald they've
done extensive research on all this
stuff go check them out but flight 77
Khalid almadar nawafal hazmi the 28
Pages the 911 report just go check that
out it's very eye-opening I thought that
for 20 years they had one story which
was it was just they were just there
working together
for fun like there was no connection and
then all of a sudden last two years more
documents came out that show the
connection to the Saudi Prince let me
let me read this from the vague so he's
uh he says Mike Pence says today that he
was deeply offended that I don't trust
that the government told us the truth
and that in the 911 Commission report
he says well I find it offensive that
our government repeatedly lies to us
here's the truth the FBI quietly
Declassified documents in 2021 that
definitively reveal the government lie
to the public about basic facts of Saudi
Arabia's involvement in 911 until
documents were Declassified and they
changed their story 20 years later Omar
al-bayumi a 42 year old graduate student
welcomed housed set up bank accounts and
gave rent money to the first two
Al-Qaeda hijackers after they landed in
Los Angeles in January of 2000 albayumi
claimed to have met the two terrorists
entirely by Chance the 911 Commission
report verified that biomi's altruism
was in the name of hospitality as he
claimed
the FBI 20 years later changed its story
and documents Declassified last year the
bureau affirmed that biomi was in fact
an agent of the Saudi intelligence
service who worked with Saudi religious
officials and reported that the
Kingdom's powerful Ambassador in
Washington U.S government officials
continue to lie about other matters of
public importance the origin of corrid
I'm sorry the origin of coven knowledge
about uaps Hunter Biden's laptop and how
our money is actually being spent in
Ukraine the Nashville Shooters Manifesto
with a complicit media that just accepts
the prevailing narrative without
question this fuels rampant public
distrust there is no credible evidence
that 911 was an inside job but
ironically when the government
systematically lies about Saudi
involvement and the media runs
interference that lends plausibility to
and otherwise unlikely claim there's no
such thing as a noble lie with all due
respect to the former VP the reason that
people don't trust the government is
because the government doesn't trust the
people man Mike very well said wow he's
great I want to vote for this guy yeah
do it yeah I do hope he wins me too I
think to be honest I don't think he's
going to win he'd need to be selected
somehow like Obama was well his deep
State needs to get involved I'm I'm
surprised he's not pulling higher
already considering he's he's broken
into second place a couple times and in
the prediction markets he has I'm
surprised he's just every time I see him
do an event he's hitting a home run he's
hitting a grand slam well he basically
he echoed or just talked about exactly
we were just talking about that 20 years
after the 911 Commission report had lied
to the American people about the
terrorists involvement with the Saudi
Prince but they didn't bring up the
Saudi Prince maybe at the time I don't
know 20 years later they they admit we
were lying when Donald Prince was
involved in funding these guys when
Donald Trump said that Chris Christie
was probably eating he said Vivek is
catching up onto sandus and he's good
yeah that was like Trump was like he's
good Vivek knows how to play the game
it's all respect between Trump and Vivek
I like it yeah defense like that in 2016
though it was uh Trump and Cruz until
right up till the end they were like
buddy buddy you know like he wouldn't
tread on Trump's shoes and then I
has handled his his reason for running
and his criticism criticisms of trump
masterfully he's defended Trump on all
the most important things praised Trump
on all the good things that he's done
and I think his core uh issue is that
he's mostly just a younger more active
and in an involved individual who thinks
that he could do a better job
what's Trump going to say to that good
luck this is one area where Trump really
messed up was with the Saudis you know
he talked about finding out what really
happened on 9 11 when he ran in 2016 and
then when he's president he's over there
with the Saruman ball with them you know
and you know Dancing With The Sword and
you know just forgetting about khashoggi
and all that so I don't know the Saudi
Arabian Prince was sending money to the
terrorist hijackers before they hijacked
the planes to mayoral biomi who was a
Saudi student in the United States yeah
middleman who then was housing and
giving Aid to Khalid al-madar and the
waffle housemate now someone funding
terrorists before they attack doesn't
necessarily mean that they were funding
the terrorist attack they might have
just been funding these guys for fun
there's no way to know but this is
damning yes this shows direct
correlation between the Saudi government
and the terrorist attacks on 9 11. and
he's on target like what he's talking
about here is the real deal I mean so
many people get distracted by I'm going
to just call them Dome conspiracies like
no planes or you know like stuff that
doesn't matter and he's he's on target
so good for him
let's jump to the story about Trump we
got this from CNN security increases for
judge assigned to Donald Trump's January
6 criminal case it all appears to be
some kind of escalation CNN has observed
more security detail to judge Tanya
chutken and Deputy U.S Marshals
discussed security plans for the judge
on Monday the U.S Marshal Service
handles security at the D.C District
Court and a spokesman for the service
that it takes that responsibility very
seriously ensuring that judges can rule
independently and free from harm or
intimidation is Paramount to the rule of
law
you know you see this and this we had
the story that we kicked off with about
that guy in Provo who the FBI killed and
it seems like
I mean look it's it seems like violence
is on the horizon
and then you think about the fact that
uh or the story about Andes Andy knows
uh yep situation yesterday how the
entire court seemed to be against
against but Andy did win
so in this particular case he loses
against these two individuals but the
court found in default found the other
defendants in default uh in default or
whatever and I think what happens is
fairly obvious Andy sues a handful of
these far left extremists
then they all meet together
and my my opinion an assumption on what
they probably did was hey you guys
actually did it so don't show up they'll
hold you in default you'll lose but we
don't want it on the record that you
actually did it then those who weren't
involved will go say I wasn't involved I
didn't attack him and then you'll get a
trial where it's Andy no loses so so he
won against a couple of defendants
already they're in default what does
that mean that they're in default it
means uh like no contest didn't show up
so they lose so they're found guilty
it's not guilty it's a Civil Trial
they're in default so they're they they
made no argument
yeah to what extent I'm not entirely
sure right against the guys who likely
attacked them they they probably and
apparently one of the guys showed up
after the fact after it was already
found in default he tried showing up in
the in the stands or whatever but uh the
story about Trump and the judge and the
judge getting more security apparently
people are saying that the judge is
that basically what's happening is
they're they're insinuating there are
very serious threats from the right
against the judge because of things
Trump's been saying and they're trying
to make it look like Trump is it
persistent and consistent threat
I support them getting security for any
judge at this point
um but I do agree that I think this
maybe is a play to make it look like
look at the way that they they behave
about the right all the time it is
constantly that the right is dangerous
we need security from the right the
right is going to do this the right is
going to do that and if you look at the
past couple years you know you've got
Justice uh Steve scalise was shot by a
Bernie Sanders supporter you got people
showing up at uh Supreme Court Justices
house is saying that they're oh we're
gonna you know I came here because I was
gonna kill the guy
um yeah but Phil a guy dressed up in a
buffalo costume and went into the
capital once right I mean that but
that's the thing it's on Michael
malice's show by the way he was today
yeah Jacob Chancellor you've got actual
you know you've got people actually
throwing
you know Molotov cocktails that police
in in Portland and all that stuff is is
mostly ignored there's an attack on the
White House that makes Trump go into the
bunker and all that's ignored but then
you know the right does anything and
then and it's it's uh that's the most
amazing hypocritical moment right there
but it's not hypocrisy I've said there's
a bunch there's this dude Herbert Marcus
who wrote papers giving the logic giving
the justification it's called Uh uh
repressive tolerance it was it came out
in 1964 an essay on tolerance I think is
what it's called came out in 1964.
Herbert Marcus is a a rock star a
philosophy of on the left he wrote a
bunch of books uh coincidentally he was
also influential when it comes to queer
theory he wrote this book called Eros
and civilization he wrote a book called
one dimensional man but all these things
that we're seeing in reality here in in
society now these things are all
at least outlined in in leftist theory
books decades and decades ago they're
just manifesting in reality now all this
stuff is completely predictable and you
can see you can just go and find the
arguments and read the arguments for
this Behavior if you want to it's not
like the right is making it up is it
fair to say that Marcus was writing like
a Playbook of how to win a cultural
revolution in the United States uh I I
don't know that he was writing a
Playbook I think that he was more a
philosopher overall than than uh than
than than an actual tactician but
possibly I don't I don't know I don't
know if you you I I would I think I
would defer to someone that's more
familiar with Mark use the stuff I
haven't studied his stuff I see I guess
there's some strategy and tactics so I
see more of a thesis I thought that was
like salinsky stuff that guy Rules for
Radicals and and he was really like a
tactics dude as opposed to so I I mean I
guess
maybe someone like Mark Hughes was a
strategy guy and then olinski is more of
a tactics guy you know like an on the
street or on the on the ground how you
actually affect these ideas or make
these ideas manifest in reality I want
to pull up this tweet from Julie Kelly
she tweets Jack Smith errantly claimed
that Trump was a Flight Risk to convince
judge Beryl Howell to prevent Trump from
knowing about the Twitter search warrant
Merrell Howell agreed that Trump would
flee from prosecution writing the
district court also found reason to
believe the former president would flee
from prosecution the government later
acknowledged however that it errantly
included flight from prosecution as a
predicate in its application
they have already laid the groundwork to
remand Trump to custody under the under
the idea that he will flee if they try
to uh to convict him and so this is what
I was saying before
if the charges against Donald Trump are
legitimate if they genuinely believe it
Trump would be locked up right now they
would not let him leave the man on
several Jets helicopters he's a
billionaire he has buildings with his
name on it he owns buildings all over
the world he could go to any one of
these countries he has the absolute
capabilities to flee the only reason he
wouldn't is because he's running for
president but they have made the
argument already we're getting this
information out of the the the Twitter
revelation
that they're trying to seek information
from his Twitter account
they're they're actually arguing now
that Trump's going to try and fully so
how long until they were man him to
custody how long until they make the
argument that Trump should not be free
and then they stop him from campaigning
I don't know I thought that they were
not gonna do that this is this just came
out today that they arantly included
flight from prosecution as a as a
predicate what does that mean they
accidentally had his his Flight Risk
in there and then they took it out I
think they what they're saying is they
did not mean to include that they feel
that Trump is a Flight Risk when facing
prosecution
yeah like what do you don't make
accidents at that level maybe maybe they
do maybe they do actually I don't know
but it seems like a convenient accident
to have that piece of data on and off
the Record at the same time I think
they're gonna lock him up they're trying
to silence him Trump's fighting back can
he still run if they lock him up yes but
he's not gonna be able to go to rallies
I mean it sounds kind of fun though I'm
kind of interested in that idea yeah I
think if they lock him up he still wins
in fact I think I think it helps him
exactly I think they know putting him in
jail is gonna give him a a major victory
look if Elon Musk is right that is the
funniest outcome like he gets arrested
and then goes to jail and then wins and
pardons himself and pardons all the
guards and then goes to DC that would be
hilarious yes but there there are many
people
throughout history who have been jailed
by the by their their government or
political Rivals and then later get out
and then win Hitler is the first one
that comes to say Hitler I was gonna say
Mandela Mandela is the other one
Napoleon was uh banished and then he
came back and went right back to the
Revolution and started attacking again
yep I don't know man I think there's a
strong possibility they lock up Trump
they're throwing everything and the
kitchen sink I think it'd be hilarious
they would piss off 100 million people
if they did that like Beyond yeah you
just that would be the worst tactic
maybe that's the real conspiracy theory
that Trump really is the the you know
the trigger no that's the war no that
Trump is deep State and in order to get
him to win with the support of the
people you need to make him into the
Martyr into the victim that people are
willing to get Beyond interesting it's
not that hard to imagine though if you
think about like so just do a thought
experiment with me for a second imagine
if Joe Biden had been president in 2020
do you think all those red Governors
would have locked their states down
yeah
um they would they would have been on
the opposite side they would have said
oh no you know yeah they would have been
like resisting the tyranny of Joe Biden
where with Donald Trump saying hey guys
we got to do this you know all the red
States kind of like okay whatever so
sometimes
yeah but the the argument would be
how do you get a Libertarian to vote for
a Republican president
no you make him the Martyr you make him
you make him the persecuted you make him
the anti-establishment you make him the
anti-government I was talking about this
with Bitcoin I was like you know if I
was a world economic Forum globalist
billionaire and I wanted a One World
Currency how would I do it because we've
heard that conspiracy over and over
again they're gonna they're gonna make a
One World Government currency you know
Alex Jones have been talking about for
decades I'm like well
you got to get the crackpot conspiracy
theorists to be the ones pushing and
advocating for it
because you come out against them then
you get that whole network of people
paying attention to politics they're
against you and they don't want they
don't want to do it so then I see
Bitcoin and all of a sudden I see the
likes of these anarchists
anti-establishment conspiracy theorist
types all saying it's the future and you
have to use it
and I'm like so this this you're calling
it I don't know if they call it a
currency these days or whatever but it's
like Global financial transaction system
that can be tracked by anyone at any
point right and they can know everything
you're doing
and you all are advocating for I'm like
that's this is like a one world unified
currency
well I mean you know I'm like I'm not
saying that that's true I'm just saying
if you want a One World Currency
Bitcoins or I should just say crypto in
general is a fast path
especially considering they can track
everything you're buying yeah I'm a gold
bug so Phil's gotta defend Bitcoin
uh I mean I'm I'm
a fan of Bitcoin as well as gold and
silver and I've got a little bit of all
that stuff I'm not a one a one-way kind
of dude
that sounds a little that the guys in
town in uh and Tower gang are gonna pay
are gonna punish me for that I like that
you can create your own crypto and use
it like locally for things even though
the government would want to take taxes
from you you can still do it and like
things like someone just texted Monero
uh Gustav said that in the chat yeah
Monero apparently is untrackable or more
challenging what happens like that what
happens when they tell Trump
they say where are you currently
residing says Bedminster New Jersey and
they say okay don't leave the state
what what about that that's a half
scenario it's like they're not jailing
them because they don't want to give
them any any hard political martyr
benefits you probably would not leave
the state go nuts on social media
they're not letting me leave the state
this is unconscionable I'm stuck here in
this beautiful palace in Bedminster you
know but I think he would stay there and
just do a lot more media I have social
media I don't know
if he went he said that he was in
Florida I imagine he couldn't get he
wouldn't get remanded to uh it's gonna
be a federal judge who says like we're
gonna release you but you have to stay
in a certain area because we want to
make sure that you don't flee blah blah
blah Maybe
I do want to see this though
what I want Trump or Amanda to custody I
think I think when the fact that they
arrested him and let him go proves
they're lying about everything
that they like they're accusing the guy
of trying to overthrow the government
they're like yeah you can go go do
whatever you want yeah so what I find
interesting is they can't you know
prosecute him for war crimes because
they'd be complicit in the same things
they tried to go after you know they got
to go after Biden Obama Bush Clinton no
boy we can go all the way back and the
like the let them go thing is like we
think you did a crime but you can go
it's kind of like here take this package
whatever you do don't take it across the
street to that 7-Eleven don't do it and
then they just watch and they're waiting
waiting for him to take the package
across the street they're like we just
want you to flee man we just want you to
do something to give us an excuse to
crack down a hundred times harder
John's got big jet he can fly wherever
he wants
so do you do you think Trump will put
his foot down on Ukraine because he yes
the again I I judge a man by what he
does not what he says and you know to
his credit he did talk to Putin and he
kept an open line of communication for
the most part but he also
was the guy who initiated lethal Aid to
Ukraine Obama like he even bragged Obama
was only sending pillows and helmets or
something like that I'm sending them
missiles and I mean he he was
responsible for a lot of the escalation
he tore up the INF treaty the open Skies
treaty you know so I don't know like I I
just don't believe what people say I
believe I do I think I think the war
ends the moment he gets elected yeah I
think Putin is going to ceasefire and
then he's gonna say we're waiting and
Trump's gonna go and I think a likely
scenario if Trump didn't get elected is
the Don bass goes to uh Russia Crimea
and the donbass go to Russia Ukraine
retains everything else fighting stops I
mean I would like to think that could
happen because it's a very low bar like
all we got to do is stop sending
billions of dollars and the war ends
which the media is even starting to
admit that now Boris Johnson went there
and disrupted peace peace agreements so
yeah NATO countries want they want war
yeah I mean look I think many in the
west the United States particular uh
particularly are saying this is our
chance to it's a castle spelling for war
with Russia we needed a way to justify
war with Russia and now we have it but
Russia needs to push harder Russia needs
to attack a NATO country so that NATO
can invade Russia that's what they want
to happen
and they'll keep doing it until Russia
has no choice I wouldn't be surprised if
you get NATO military forces firing from
inside NATO territory at Russians
you've already got a story about a
Russian strike that it was 600 feet from
Romania or something like that so we're
getting dangerously close
Donald Trump is going to go in and be
like nope no more fighting he's going to
go to the he's going to go to Ukraine
but you're not getting any more money
from us and they're going to go okay we
want peace no more funding no more
military you they're not going to be
able to support any any effort against
Russia how entangled do you think the
Deep state is with this war right now
how much vested interest do they have in
seeing it 100 then they'll assassinate
him if he tries to stop it I I see one
thing you you mean to say they'll try
they'll try they'll try over and over
and over and over and over one big
problem with your theory I have is uh
Lindsey Graham how close that guy still
is with Trump I mean he is like the
epitome of everything we're talking
about
I think
Donald Trump Wants Revenge too much
when he goes in he is going to be just
screaming at the top of his lungs I'm
not saying it's absolute I'm just saying
what they've done to him now
assuming it's all on the level rating
his house going after his family
whatever he's he's gonna go and he's
going to scream at these people he's
going to be like you're weak you stabbed
me in the back Lindsey Graham sure maybe
but Lindsey Graham what's he doing to
help Trump right now nothing these guys
abandoned with him a little bit Yeah
they but they abandon him across the
board so Donald Trump may be not perfect
there's a strong possibility you get a
bunch of BS but I'll you know I'll flip
the coin I think there's a good the best
candidate right now for firing people in
government hey maybe it's one guy I'll
take it it's gonna be Trump no I don't
think so I think it's fake because he
talks about you can't literally fire
people uh you can shut down
um like sectors of the of the government
where people work and then their jobs
are dissipated and they no longer work
there you can't do individual firings
um Trump didn't know that apparently
when he was in office he's like I can't
fire them but he could have shut shut
them down and he didn't I I think he's
not in a good I don't know I don't want
to assume too much but it seems like
Trump's not in a very good State of Mind
relative to 2016 when he was like we're
gonna make America great he was talking
about making things great now he's
talking about like I'm gonna go get him
you let me back in there I'm gonna get
him Revenge I don't want that I mean in
2016 he talked about the Federal Reserve
and the bubble economy we've created and
how lowering interest rates artificially
is going to cause problems and then as
soon as he became president without
addressing any of it it was instantly
the greatest economy in the world
everything's fine you know so he has a
way of talking about the problems when
he's not in there and then as soon as he
gets in he has awful people you know
talking him up and you know schmoozing
him and everything and then he just kind
of I don't know he listens to bad advice
a lot I feel like his instincts are
better than the the governing he's done
but you know he's just he he likes
flattery he likes being worshiped so
that's so dangerous yes Ian you said uh
that you don't want someone that's going
to go in there and get him that's
exactly what I want I want someone
that's going to go in there and
disassemble portions of the government
like I want someone that's going to go
in there and get them that look I want
someone that looks at them as a problem
that needs to be remedied the
bureaucracy in in Washington needs to be
disassembled absolutely that's the
biggest problem the United States has
right now is the massive amounts of
bureaucracy probably the security
apparatus that was built after 9 11 has
to be totally disassembled it has to be
because it's been turned on the American
people now so whoever's gonna think yeah
whoever's going to do the most
disassembling and I mean it whoever's
going to do the most damage to the
bureaucracy and by damage I mean
disassembling like taking it apart
firing people like getting rid of people
that are working for the for the
government ending contracts this is I'm
talking about serious serious cuts to
the government like P we get we get a
lot of people coming in here and talking
about like oh I want to do this and I
want to do that and stuff I want the
guys that are like I'm going to take the
government apart because it's too big
it's the biggest government in human
history and it's totally it has so much
redundancy so much unnecessary uh Power
And So It violates the the rights of of
people in in the United States in every
imaginable way every single bill every
single amendment in the Bill of Rights
is violated in some way nowadays by the
federal government and we should take
the government apart and stop them I
agree the distance about disassembly I'm
concerned about the methodology because
the two guys that have been talking
about are Trump and Rama Swami and like
vivek's pretty uh articulate and um
architectural about the way he wants to
end certain programs replace them with
some or in some instances not replace
them with anything as opposed to the
what I'm hearing from Trump and I
haven't really talked to him about it is
uh I want to go get them I'm I'm going
back in there to get them and it's like
I want to hear about your structural
reform I don't really care about the
people that much I mean that's not
that's never been true that's gonna say
that's Trump
literally like that's like not whether
whether or not Trump has Trump never has
a plan for that I don't think that
he has any kind of plan he's going to go
in there and be like how do I take
things apart take that apart take this
part he's not he's going to be honest if
you're Google how to disassemble federal
government and then he'll have to rely
on advice and the people that play Shell
Games with them and be like yeah
actually you can't disassemble that one
and he'll be like really and then like
six weeks will go by and he'll be like
why can't we do it guys whereas vivex
like stomping his foot like sign this
piece of legislation I've read the
Constitution 30 times like he knows
exactly where to move and to put the
pieces to to take this thing apart in a
way that won't destroy it I want the
destruction well disassembly and
destruction are two different no they're
not supposed to take something apart no
they're not I mean you could argue no
they are they are if you disassemble if
you destroy it I mean you could argue
that disassembly is a form of
Destruction I wanted I want disassembled
in a manner in which it does not
function anymore so whether you call it
disassembly I'm saying disassembly so
that way I sound nice and reasonable you
can call it you can call it murder the
government you can call it destroy you
can say you can use whatever art you can
you know articulate however you want
however you want not like the guy in
Utah you know that that that's that was
a very end there was a specific
individual I'm talking about the
government broadly the bureaucracy so I
don't care if you want if you if you
talk about you know how you describe it
I want the bureaucracy the function of
the bureaucracy currently to end and the
people that work in the bureaucracy to
work in other fields that are no longer
in the government like and then I want
the buildings that house the bureaucracy
to be raised to the ground or sold you
know but like I want to like actual
elimination of government bureaucracy
not restructure not give it up move it
around not a shell game I'm talking
about get rid of jobs in the government
because I want the government smaller
than it is is and there's and I think
there's too many people that that will
say that especially even or even
Libertarians or small government people
they'll say oh we want to limit this and
limit that but then they would never
ever say I want to get rid of jobs
they'll never actually say they want to
make real Cuts I want real Cuts real
real Cuts real painful cuts to the
government I guess technically they'd be
layoffs not not firings but layoffs I
don't care how do you call call them
what you want I just want them not doing
their job anymore I want those jobs gone
I want those jobs if it totally
destroyed this is what they did in Iraq
though you've got to be careful with the
battle party that was getting rid of
people that had a political that was
getting rid of a political ideology in
in the bath party we're saying the bath
parties rid of the party the party
ideology I'm saying get rid of the
function
so like the I when you talk about
getting into the bath party you they
what they did is they got rid of people
that had an ideological perspective
that's like Saddam Hussein's political
party it's like getting rid of
Republicans what I'm saying is get rid
of whatever the function that the
government that this agency does
whatever their job is make the
government no longer have that job so
it's not getting rid of ideology it's
removing a function of the government
all right we're gonna go to Super Chat
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends take that URL on YouTube post it
wherever you can it really does help and
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up in about a
half an hour and right now I put up a
poll on YouTube should we keep rise with
Roberto Jr or create a memorial blend
for Roberto Jr as of right now
73 think we should immortalize rise with
Roberto Jr so
if by the end of tonight's show that is
the dominant preference among all of you
what I'm gonna do is
we will
alter the art on the existing rise with
Roberto Jr coffee blend in uh to add the
his his date of birth and his date of
death and in memoriam on the back but we
will keep it in every other way the same
which means the existing bags that we
have we actually have a few thousand
that are still available will be the
last time those are printed but we will
keep it overwhelmingly the same I just
feel like I don't want to do nothing I
don't want to just have the same thing
like we did nothing you know Roberto Jr
our favorite rooster he dies and we're
just like yeah we'll just keep it no no
we'll make a new bag art so that means
that the existing art will be unique and
then there will be a very very similar
but we'll say in memoriam with his you
know life on the back I think that's
that that's the appropriate thing if you
all agree that we should immortalize the
rise with Roberto Jr blend I love that
the term rise with Roberto now takes on
new meaning it's like a spirit it's like
an elevation of spirit man
well the Return of the King we have to
make a new blend for Roberto who's
returned or the Beast he's come back
because uh his son passed and he's got
to take care of uh his grandkids is he
in there now yeah oh okay he's out there
but uh we'll read some more Super chats
let's let's get on with it I'm not your
buddy guy always the first he says they
aren't protecting Biden they're
protecting Obama but it just so happens
to be the key connection to unraveling
the Intel influence
perhaps Mick zenmancer says did I beat
I'm not your buddy guy for first oh so
no you didn't you were six minutes late
sorry
where are we at Kenneth Hart says your
show is not kid safe bro we visited my
library mom who of course rescued a
pitbull I catch my oldest son wiggling
his jowls copying Tim's imitation of
Obama saying too many kids gotta blow
him up he put too many pits
that was that was a just Sheamus nobody
gets gotta blow up yeah so I made the
joke where it's like Barack Obama's like
if you vote for me I'm gonna blow up
kids and then Sheamus was like gotta
blob kids too many of them hope you
gotta change the population
Tom mannion says defend the guard thanks
for representing the bill Reed you got
it
let's grab some more Super chairs
SR-71 industry says Tim and gang thank
you my channel would be where it is
today without you I do car Enthusiast
gaming soon Health and Fitness for truck
drivers guns and gear this veteran
appreciates it rip Roberto much love
Roberto Jr but I appreciate sentiment
Roberto is his father who has returned
his name is Roberto beaks and it was
Roberto beaks Jr and Roberto beaks Mr
beaks he's back
William tresh says Tim what are you
talking about that nothing happened in
the left threatened Trump Republicans
sent so many strongly worded letters
they did I remember those how dare you
they were shaking their fist at clouds
Matthew Maddox says people tried to burn
down the White House with Trump inside
they did and uh January 6 is more
important I suppose
there you go
let's go
or dantech says they definitely came
after people who threatened Trump I got
a visit at work from the SS because of
an Epstein meme I had him and Kennedy in
the same sentence and they cornered me
at work and I'm a random nobody but
that's what I was saying we've heard all
these stories about them knocking on
doors the question is what happened with
this guy in Provo I think he probably
shoved to his door with a gun and then
they were like nope and he was like nope
and then this is what happens yeah I
think he he probably got Lippy dummy
Mike E says had to send to my dog of 15
years Over the Rainbow Bridge today can
y'all please shout out my dog Abby one
of the greatest dogs ever Abby may your
spirit rest in peace sorry to hear it
Mike rest in peace Abby Abby
OMG puppies says the Democratic party
controls the media and that's all that
matters Aristotle said this 2 400 years
ago democracy is ruled by whoever
Masters rhetoric
agreed
yep they have a strong influence over it
I don't know not full control but
definitely strong influence
Ryan Spalding says the cover art of
Megadeth's the system has failed album
really resonates with current events and
that album was released in early 2000s
do you know do you know that one the
cover of Googling right now the system
has failed hmm
Brian barwinski says Ian is grounded and
Crystal pilled tonight 20. oh thank you
oh very nice very nice I've been holding
this Ruby as we talk a ruby huh we got
to give you that charged Crystal it's
just sitting on our counter let's bring
it yeah I gotta bring it over
Colton heyers says I think it's
incredibly stupid to vote for whoever
will make your opponents the angriest
vote for whoever can bring the most
change I see that in Vivek and not in
Trump anymore don't troll vote
I like Vivek I want to vote for him in
the primary
we'll see though we'll see though I
think I think it's gonna go Trump
but it would be pretty amazing if uh
Trump picks for fake for VP I'm not not
entirely sure that would happen though
what do you guys think you think he'll
probably offer it to him I feel like Tim
Scott
yeah not Lindsey Graham that 80 year old
like if he chose Lindsey Graham he loses
yeah hands down because there are people
who vote for Trump but don't like Trump
right what do you put Lindsey Grandma to
take it and they're just like I'm out
there's this uh thing about RFK and
Trump uniting and running have you ever
heard of that yeah absolutely do you
think that could happen or is it
ridiculous I don't think it's I mean
it's a little ridiculous but I think
could happen you know uh Trump is a New
York uh uh he's a Democrat I mean yeah I
I want to say like he's conservative by
New York standards today you know what I
mean but he's like an old school
Democrat yeah right and so rfk's got a
lot of bad positions and a lot of pass
positions that are that are questionable
but uh I kind of just want to see
Insurgent candidates storm the gates you
know what I mean they go in they walk in
and it's like we're in charge now you're
fired you're fired you're fired sign
this bill you know yep
man we gotta we gotta have something
going on
14 all says Elon did hand over Trump's
account to the government in the end
though this is only being half reported
yes that is true
so the question is was it Elon trying to
obstruct was he strong-armed
let's see defect says what do you think
about the Department of Education I just
found out their annual budget is 270
billion more than 10 times that of NASA
it doesn't seem we are getting the value
for the money doesn't seem we're
literally not and also they're they're
uh their budget goes up every year and
test scores go down have gone down every
year
every single year they have been lower
than the previous year since the
Inception of the Department of Education
that would be if you split up what is a
270 billion among five 50 states you'd
have what was the math I don't know what
the math is there six to six six billion
5 billion per state something like that
that's a lot of money that you could you
could give out to the states directly
it's the most important uh Department
that we could abolish on a
on a uh what's the word I'm looking for
not foreign policy on a uh domestic
domestic level yeah yeah I agree with
that probably yeah
all right Nathan Rossman Baker says
Vivek love them and all cannot win none
of your guests can even say his name
right and they are politically clued in
I think that I I I I I don't necessarily
disagree with that the fact that no one
can say his name actually matters
because the dude has been speaking a lot
now granted people are going to read
things phonetically they're going to say
Vivek when his name is Vivek but it
seems like no matter how many times
we've brought it up no matter how many
times it comes up we've even corrected
people on the show and they still won't
say his name also Morrowind Elder
Scrolls 3 vivek's one of the Gods Viv EC
spelled a little different so Vivek is
in the Consciousness already but it's
Vivek but we've had guests where we're
back it's Vivek like cake and they'll go
oh okay and then 20 minutes later
they're like well Vivek is saying Vivek
some people will be like I don't know
he's he's relatively new into the social
Consciousness and he may not win this
time I'm not I don't know I want to
manifest his victory but at the same
time he might just win in 2028. there's
a reason all his yard signs say truth
not his name on them wild yeah at least
in New Hampshire that's what they'll say
really Dom G says the fourth amendment
is not limited to your home it includes
your person houses papers and effects
looking through my messages is like
looking through my mail Ian Roland zeros
looking in my eyeballs is like looking
into my mind man get out of it no come
on dude but that's true the four the
Fourth Amendment does he's right if if
you have a stack of papers in your
office laying on a desk the fourth
amendment protects them from the
government walking up and just grabbing
them and reading them yeah the the it's
it's it's extensive historically though
found that it's it's an extensive uh
protection imagine you rent an office
in a big building
and you've got paper sitting on your
desk so the government goes to the
building's owner and says we're gonna go
in and take all these private messages
because they're actually yours because
they're in your building and he goes
deal yeah it sounds like Patriot Act
sounds like complete nonsense
we'll grab some more James Dineen says
Ian what's your favorite flavor of boot
oh straight up nice weather dude so you
can actually eat leather yeah they say I
I read somewhere if you're starving you
gotta eat your leather off your shoes
and shoe it up it's animal hide
how does it just last forever like what
bacteria can't eat it but you can or
what I don't know
we will get some more Super chats what
we have here Mister Howie Howie says Tim
you mentioned a memorial statue for
Roberto Jr I'm a professional sculptor
I'm up for it in fact I just emailed a
3D render of a fun version of RJ I've
been working on recently have a look uh
where did you email it I will write down
your name we yeah we should do this Mr
Howie Howie
but I'm just writing how we squared so I
have to write Howie twice
uh yeah it would be great we'll get a
little statue of Roberto Jr we'll put it
by chicken City
like a Weather Vein we should get a
Weather Vein of him just constantly
spinning around it's actually a good
idea we have to put it way up high
though if you actually you know so a
little statue is probably you know
Redbox says Phil why would you judge RFK
Jr based on his past positions rather
than his most recent modified positions
that lean more center right
because he held the past positions for
longer judge a man by what he does
because he's got history and and uh
behavior that that you know shows that
he endorses those things the the most
recent stuff could possibly be changing
for what is politically expedient
whereas the things that he uh says has
said consistently in the past probably
reflect his real opinions uh
so that's that's why
silence do better says only three
percent of the American population
participated in the revolution it does
not take a majority to Prevail but
rather an Irate tireless minority keen
on setting brush fires of freedom in the
minds of men Samuel Adams well
I feel like it's easier to fight a war
back then than it is now like with the
spread of information and with the well
there's porn on the Internet yeah I I
disagree I think it's easier now than
it's ever been uh offense has become uh
increasingly one thing we see is that
throughout history offense has increased
faster than defense defense is
incredibly difficult and always has been
you get to the point where you know when
you have clubs and stuff someone makes a
shield and you're fairly equal in your
defense and offense you swing the club
you block it and deflected with the
shield you swing with your Club he
blocks it and then we get bows and
arrows and now you have high speed
projectile weapons that can penetrate
three shell hit your arm hit you in the
leg break through your armor even rip
through plate so once they Advance
between you know from chain mail to
Plate now you've still got offensive
capabilities then you get gunpowder now
all of a sudden armor made no sense it's
like the musket ball is gonna rip
through whatever you're wearing anyway
so you're better off having a light
soldier who can carry more and move
faster because we're using Muscat
foreign we do have bulletproof vests we
do have all these things but the reality
of warfare is today you have cyber
capabilities the ability to manipulate
hundreds of millions of people overnight
instantly viruses to destroy their
economy and take out their new their
electrical plants their grid
in the snap of a finger the entire Grid
in the world could be shut down I'm sure
that every government has a button they
could press because they've already
hacked and installed viruses on everyone
else's machines so we don't even need
the minute you know time frame for the
ICBM to launch into the air to shut a
city down now they can just click a
button Grid's gone right okay I think
like war in general is easier to fight
but the likelihood of someone in this
country grabbing a rifle and heading to
go fight a war I think that is less just
because of the amount of uh ease people
live with now the amount of technology
that makes their life enjoyable I mean
back in the day that's acting like
you know uh people can afford their rent
and people can afford food there's
entire right I think those things have
to go before like any Revolution yeah
like any civilian has to get that
miserable before there's any sort of
actual big conflict but then you're not
saying anything different right so when
people in France were fed they didn't
want a revolution and then when the
famine came they wanted Revolution yeah
the same thing is true for Tunisia and
and and Egypt the cost of bread was
going up that's that's uh that's not
that's a
every every revolution has to a certain
degree to a certain degree that in
common yeah some kind of lack of direct
access I think it's a uh what was his
names the hierarchy of needs what's the
guy's name Maslow Maslow's hierarchy of
needs when you disrupt these things
people get mad and they'll fight for
them food is a critical component yeah
so for a lot of people who are you know
very very fat so long as the Communists
keep people fed there ain't going to be
a revolution just theirs or there won't
be a civil war just a revolution so they
got to make sure everyone's fat and
happy and they'll be like well I got
food I ain't gonna fight yeah but but I
will also add saying that it's harder
for people today to pick up like a rifle
or something uh it there's always
organization to these conflicts I think
anybody who's like thinking they're
gonna run out and grab a gun is stupid
they shouldn't do anything like that we
we want to win where the conflict
actually occurs and today it's a culture
War we need to win the culture we want
to win in the legal front and I would I
would say it's like saying people are
much less likely to pick up a sword
today it's like well that's not the
effective means of conflict the effects
of means of conflict today are
manipulation in your mind social media
think people just still think of a
generic Civil War when when they hear
that term they think of like north and
south or Republicans and Democrats like
right grabbing their guns and fighting
each other and I don't think that's and
that's like saying when you say War but
it's like what people running around
with swords and shields fighting in the
streets like no no dude that was
thousands of years ago what you mean
like people with guns no dude that was
100 200 years ago people going online
right now we are being faced with a
cultural revolution and it is being
actively resisted and there are two
principal factions at odds over who is
I'm glad to say that it's substantially
less violent I hope we don't get any
violence but like this is it are we
going to win the cultural battle or end
up in prisons
let's read some more
wait what is this
I'm not gonna read that because I can't
verify it right now
all right Petra says hey Tim and crew
can I get a shout out to my wife and I
just found out we're expecting our first
child oh congratulations Congress
something happened in the Ecuadorian
president yeah yeah well no not the
president the someone that was running
for president was assassinated whoa
there's a video going around of it so
yeah it happened uh at like a political
rally I think so it's definitely
verifiable I can say wow
Josh says re-ex it'll end up being
enabled by enabled on the app only not
the browser for security reasons the
only solution I know that addresses this
is Sif which has Quantum resistant in
browser code signing
and they always got some way to bypass
encryption man
two steps ahead for for a reason
and they force people to install
backdoors because they have guns
all right what's this
Tim Brackett says rip Roberto Jr really
do appreciate it
Ryan Chrisman says one of the president
presidential candidates in Ecuador was
assassinated today at a campaign rally
WTF wow my name is guy's name is
Fernando uh villaviciencio
Dreadnought Trucking LLC says if somehow
either trumps beat the charges on his
own or the Supreme Court gets involved I
am predicting now with 200 confidence
that Vivek will be Trump's VP and in 28
it will be Vivek as Perez and Rand Paul
as VP
those are bold predictions I think you
can you can take those odds Up in Vegas
and if you get it right you'll be a
millionaire
Sean Kennelly says canelli Kennelly Long
Live Roberto Jr he and your constant
talk about roosters was the inspiration
for my business name roosters Property
Maintenance my tagline reliable as the
rooster Tim just keep being Tim all the
cast Castle rocks Vivek 2024. I like the
vague man he's a good dude
yeah Roberto's returned he's a guy
Roberto Jim's got Brothers you know but
none of them are Robert of the you know
are Roberto ask so we got to figure out
who's gonna take the mantle of Roberto
III I need to figure out how many sons
he's had we think he has a couple and so
one of them is gonna have to be Roberto
III
yeah they do they would do that in the
Middle Ages too someone would just take
a new name as like the seventh or
something you know the Scottish king
would become people still do that isn't
James O'Keefe the Third
there's three of them that's a good
amount third one was the best one
apparently I'm sure the other ones were
good too but this current this current
one is is a good James O'Keefe yeah
James the second looks at you James
second was probably good he made James
the third yeah James third is pretty
based
Paul taskelo says Tim I'm a 38 year old
lawyer I feel a call to use my skills
for good I'd love to contribute to the
show plus share my stories experience
with classified docs fisa warrants
National Security Presidential pardons
Obama and nuclear weapons well all right
uh sure I guess
um I don't know how
you can reach out through our
emails or whatever I always just tell
people the message Ian
he's on Twitter
good luck what do you need to do you
want to get he's a lawyer yeah is there
a jobs email or anything where people
submit for jobs uh on the Discord I
think we have that yeah on the members
Discord we have that stuff
Diego Rivera says Reed can you explain
how defend the guard uses radical
decentralization to reign in the war
party
yeah so defend the guard is a
state-by-state legislation that makes it
impossible for the president to send
troops overseas unless there has been a
declaration of war we have not declared
war since World War II but of course
we've been to Vietnam uh you know
Afghanistan Iraq Korea everywhere Korea
Panama
um so uh actually during Hurricane
Katrina I think 60 percent of
Louisiana's national guard was in Iraq
um just to show you like how many
national Guardsmen end up over there so
this would be passed state by state in
every state that passes it would
disallow the government from sending
National Guard troops unless Congress
passes a declaration of war which is a
60 majority which is pretty hard to do
and also if a congressman is actually
signing his name behind a war you know
that takes a little bit of selling to
the public and a little bit of
responsibility so it's a lot harder to
happen than the president just deciding
to send people somewhere for some
military operation it hasn't passed in
any state yet but it passed I think the
senate in Arizona and I forget what
other state it passed one of the
legislative branches
um and is picking up steam so check it
out uh you can support it in your own
State it's the most important anti-war
legislation on the books right now is
there a website for it yeah it's I think
it's uh uh bring our troops home.com or
defend the guard
you're probably just Google defend the
guard I think it's on here isn't it
yeah just Google defend the guard you'll
find it jatric penifer says I've got the
solution what does the crew think Trump
as president being our monster RFK
Junior's attorney general Trump hates
them all RFK has proven he's willing to
go after them Plus for Vegas Secretary
of State as counter wef fighting the
fight abroad is RFK even a lawyer
isn't that what he isn't that what he
was I have no idea
yeah wasn't he like fighting uh for
people who are having uh coal sludge
dumped in their rivers or something like
that back in the day oh yeah he's a
lawyer yeah yeah Environmental Lawyer
yeah
I love this you go to Wikipedia it says
he's an American Environmental Lawyer
politician and writer known for
advocating anti-vaccine misinformation
oh my gosh of course
it was so Wikipedia was so like
potentially awesome I mean it's still a
guess is if you could get a hold of a
code it depends no it depends on the
topic like if you're if you're going to
something that doesn't really get
touched by politics or that's that's
somewhat insulated from politics it's
pretty good if you go to and to things
that can be touched by politics it's
getting really bad and it's continuing
to get bad science are you talking about
like biology like we can't even nobody
knows what a man or a woman is on
Wikipedia I just realized something
I know the first thing Roberto is going
to do once we let him out his little
little house into chicken City what's
that you know what he's going to do
going right for her he's going right for
her
Roberto has been at cocktown for the
past like something like a year wow
Roberto Jr he took over you know he was
in charge of all the ladies Roberto
hasn't seen a woman in some time wow
yeah so you know he he we we had to send
him off because we didn't want him you
know mixing it with his kids because
roosters don't think twice about that
yeah you know so but uh he's gonna come
out he hadn't seen a lady in a long time
wow get it on camera it's gonna be on
camera on chicken City the wonders of
the birds and the bees for everyone to
watch live
let's grab some more support looks like
we've got defendtheguard.us uh for Bill
and bring our troops home.us for the org
thank you
Rivera said then thank you
Jason Dobson says why would you trust
somebody as president who previously
headed a pharmaceutical company more
power to Big Pharma is a scary thing
well I don't trust him because of it but
I like his uh experience within the
organization itself he knows how to
disassemble the thing but I don't
immediately think all pharmaceutical
companies are bad right you know like I
don't like the big ones but there are
smaller ones too the question is what
did his company do and did they do bad
things if they did bad things then he
should be criticized and challenged on
his bad things but uh I don't know maybe
we should we should dig into that he
knows a lot about loopholes that the
pharmaceutical companies use
um and was talking about them on the
Patrick Bet David Town Hall it was
really really a great town hall from
last week check it out and like they
said themselves previously headed a
pharmaceutical company it's not
necessarily giving more power to Big
Pharma and it's not it's not considered
a bio it's not considered pharmaceutical
it's a biotech company biotech so they
do technology and Drug development he
said they brought five drugs to patent I
think yeah
so I guess is that pharmaceutical
company
I wouldn't call it that it they they
they what does it say uh technology
portfolio includes blah blah clinical
trial data data for pharmaceutical
development blah blah blah I mean I
think if you have a concern uh
legitimate concern Jason Dobson I I
respect and agree with it you should
start looking into the company and see
what you find and then we should talk
about it you know he ran a company what
did his company do there's criticisms
over how Trump ran his companies sure
and then I think for the most part I'm
not super concerned with the real estate
you know company and what he was doing
and the left certainly is but uh you
know
what what's what's inherently wrong with
making drugs to cure diseases or
whatever if he was treating symptoms and
perpetuating a lot of awful garbage I
think we asked him about it right
Ward spose says put the Royal Chicken
Family Tree on it on what
on the coffee bag oh yeah
well I guess yeah I guess people mostly
agree we should uh keep rise with
Roberto Jr but I think we'll we'll just
right on the back you know of of all
future bags a special lineage brand
where it shows all there so the way it
works is we pre-order bags the bags are
printed it takes a long time to make it
takes like a month and a half to make
the bags so we order a ton of bags the
coffee is then brewed in short in small
batches and uh made fresh and then
packaged and sent off uh in in so it's
relatively small batches so I think we
have like 5 000 bags empty ready to be
loaded when when we start selling more
product so after this run which is
there's five thousand so you know you'll
probably you'll probably have some time
if you want to buy one there will no
longer be the original bag so these bags
are first edition bags
that was unexpectedly uh they became
very sought after very quickly well
maybe not I don't know maybe nobody
really cares but if you want to have an
original bag get them now because we're
going to add the rest in peace Roberto
Jr in memoriam on the back of the new
ones so effectively creating a unique
a unique bag you will never be able to
get again
and then I'm really excited for Return
of the King Roberto's return to the king
we should make a really strong like
espresso yeah there we go yeah because
he was only removed because of
circumstance he wasn't never violent
he's never angry did he get did he rough
him hard well he got like his son we had
to put him in jail because he was uh
roughing up the girls big daddy do they
ever come back from that when they
become aggressive they tone down well
the issue is that you know there are
Spurs get really big when they get older
and it starts hurting the girls okay
yeah okay and trimming the Spurs is like
abuse to the little Luke's figuring it
out we're really proud of him yeah all
right everybody we're gonna go to the
members only section of the show portion
of the show so head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member and we're
going to talk about naughty things so uh
not for the not for the kids it's a bit
more wild portion of the show but uh you
can submit questions and every night we
choose four or five callers to talk to
us and our guests it's a whole lot of
fun best part of the show in my opinion
so join us at timcast.com should be up
in a few minutes you can follow the show
at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast read do you want
to shout anything out yeah uh check out
defend the guard
um check out the free state project
um and then I haven't done a show in a
while but you can check out my stuff at
read Coverdale on Twitter
um I'm with Tower gang too and is Clint
joining the team soon is that the thing
I hope so I don't know we've been
talking to him about it okay I don't
know if anything's on the books yet I
love having Clint yeah no Clint's a good
friend of mine and you know we have
Tower gang I haven't done that in a
while either I've just been busy working
but uh check out my show the naturalist
capitalist
I am Phil Labonte uh the band is All
That Remains we you can check us out on
Apple music Spotify
uh what is it YouTube
Pandora we're on there yeah cheers have
an excellent rest of your day you guys
I'm Ian Crossland great to be here Reed
always good to see you man thanks for
the data coming in hot and strong baby
catch you later man
and I'm serge.com looking forward to
this after show uh let's get to it Tim
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out come hang out with us at timcast.com
we're going to be live in a few minutes
and we'll see you all there